welcome to GDC we print we're presenting
the mix today this is 2016 gamespot
presents the mix and we are so excited
were me showing you nine indie games
throughout the day to start off our
awesome GDC week and i am here with
mitch from Harebrained Schemes that's me
that's right and you're gonna be showing
meet an Acropolis that's true I am it's
just a sweet dungeon Carly let's get
right into its weird sweets no there's
only oh there's only you right now but
this is actually a four player that's
right up to 4-player co-op yeah it's a
lot of fun because the whole idea behind
this game is how far can you get so
necropolis is what we call a diabolical
dungeon delve I'm running around here
and what you'll see is that the game is
procedurally generated which means that
every game is different huh right and
you never know who yeah you never know
what you're gonna get yay so please so
it's all about killing guys and taking
their crap now I'm in addition to maybe
the enemies popping up being
procedurally generated are you saying
that the actual level designer is all
you every time pletely procedurally
generated as are the enemies as is the
loot all sorts of stuff yet as loot
shared amongst people or is it every
dude Oh No so its co-op so you can play
with your friends but there will be a
little inner party figuring out who gets
the loot can you fight each other for
loot yeah I mean you know I don't
recommend I don't recommend it so in
this game by the way you've gotta you
can see you've got a weapon and you've
got a shield you can carry two of each
you could also have different armor sets
and you can do a heavy attack which I
just did some light attacks and then
hold on let me see if I can mail okay
yeah I'm very happy right now but you
also have these power attacks I'll try
one right now just give an idea we power
up and then what are we you know that
does very effective TAFIa it's pretty
cool I mean no are all these attacks the
same for each character there any unique
actors with difference no there's only a
one character in the game this generic
adventure we call the blackguard but we
hope to add more adventures in the
future Susan in success so what are you
trying to do right now you're just
dungeon crawling forever what city idea
so what happens is a lot Duncan is
crystal yeah the idea is the Necropolis
was actually created by an art major
abraxis that wasn't some years ago and
he left a character called the brazen
Elish it is a diabolical dungeon del and
he left a caretaker named the brazen
head to take care of it and you have
been usually up invited here and you
don't know exactly why I'm through the
course of adventuring you find out what
the brazen has real well hello little
buddy if I this is not the time for that
oh I'm about to by the way one of the
cool things about this game is we're
about to find out because I'm completely
out of stamina oh that's right no you do
you have the ability to get some health
right you can you eat to regain your
health yeah you can let's try it right
now and also there's this crafting thing
but I think what we're finding out here
is that we've hit some sort of bizarre
but okay look I'm excited about the
whole thing on live streaming TV but the
idea is that it's also a permadeath game
which means that when you die you go
right back to the beginning of the game
it's like the old coin op games you just
see how far you can get so what we're
gonna do now is uh exit yeah do you want
to give it a go just give it another go
all right okay in the beginning so this
is um you're falling through no I did
that on purpose cool this is a wave
speed running through
oh it looks like you don't take fall
damage not too much no so I'm pleased
about that let's see if I can get past
these guys maybe find some other guys to
get dead with this is the old Dark Souls
method where you just run past enemies
and jess has Nicko know what the way we
came up with this title in the first
place is the the team said they asked
this question they said what would
happen if dark souls and spelunky had a
baby mm-hmm and this is the result so
yeah we've got permadeath we've got
procedurally crap we got procedurally
generated I gotta watch this thesis ah
man spike floor you also said there's a
crafting system there is if you look
right here you'll see that when you kill
something it droplet hold on okay so
opening up the menu does not cause the
game oh no no no it's on the minute that
you start the game it's alright so i
would have to do this I'll run away a
little bit and hopefully up maybe I can
get them to go through this oh you're
putting them on traps yeah I am what's
great that you can use the environment
exam against so you can see there's all
sorts of things you'd pick up up and do
it dad yeah it's not gonna go well so
this is a difficult game oh this is uh
this is a hardcore game now how long
would be a playthrough if you were
really good and you are ready say was
really really close you can see I'm
obviously not but we figure about four
to six hours okay right depends actually
on is clunky ish time depending on how
good you are yeah there's a lot to find
in here there's a there's all sorts of
exploration in the game to do another
run through 30 far we can get no are
there different seeds like what if I
wanted to play the same dungeon nope
you're going to randomize every time
okay
go okay oh you know what I know where
there's a secret room until I should try
and use that I feel good about this so
far yeah this is going typically please
like all permadeath games are going well
until you're dead yeah I noticed that
every time I play the game here all
right no no come on yeah it looks like
it can absolutely punish you for your
heavy oh yeah definitely and the other
thing is you'll see that blue bar is
your stamina bar mm-hmm so every time I
use that special attack right right my
stamina reduces and one of the fun
things about it like we are talking
about is the crafting one of the things
I can craft is a potion of vitality
mm-hmm and that will bring things back
and stuff so it's fun to just fight
enemies craft new stuff keep going down
the only exit you know is down what
found something I found a little secret
treasure box let's see we got here well
it's an unknown potion and a magic
scroll cuz you show me your inventory
one more time all the people trying to
kill you and so here about inventory you
can see you can have up to 10 things in
the inventory at one time and so here's
an unknown potion till I get a scroll of
identification I won't know what those
potions are I can use them in combat and
hope for the best some of them are curse
it's like blindness and things like can
you use a bad potion against your
enemies can you throw it or no although
there are moms in the game and they're
also besides having shields there are
also left hand weapons like magic wands
that give you ranged attacks too hmm so
that's a good one and then you'll also
see here's the crafting menu and so by
killing enemies or exploration
boringness yeah this game knows it's a
game yeah you know so it's kind of like
what if Conan the Barbarian you know met
cabin in the woods
it's an exact same yeah yeah absolutely
so by gathering all these different
materials I can craft stuff on the flyer
and create much-needed potions and
things like that
what kind of rewards can people expect
to see like the further they get a lot
there's a well first of all there's a
ton you know we're only scratching the
surface so to speak of the environment
so there's all sorts of things see the
oh sorry little buddy it's just I really
didn't even look bad he looked noe well
he has a secret but mostly what i wanted
to him from him was his essential oils
which will allow me to craft some
important stuff alright alright but what
you'll find is that the Necropolis isn't
let's hope for the best good the
Necropolis is not just a pyramid it
turns out that it's actually a pocket
dimension that the Archmage abraxis
created so that where he just scoops up
different different places and just puts
them in the Necropolis ok so you'll find
this a swamp level and a fire love all
sorts of different things lots of
different environments besides this one
oh yeah and you'll find all sorts of
enemies and weapons and things like that
good look here what's down here yeah
let's see oh there's a little chest down
there alright let's see what's in it
let's hope for the best they're bad
chest oh no there's no bad chest there's
bad items but you know what what this
sounds good yeah I like this at voice oh
yeah nice and so each individual weapon
has a completely hi everybody has its
own animation set and so they all played
very very differently
can we see the heavy on that yeah let's
do it all right so here's the heavy
kuwata all right and then you use your
special yeah BAM nice all right here's
this special well that's sweet all right
all right well that went really fast but
that was necropolis Thank You mr. Shue
need to be here and thanks for letting
me show it to you absolutely metropolis
is coming out this summer and it'll be
on steam on PC it also be on PlayStation
4 and Xbox one how are sweet and is
there a price on it yet it is thirty
dollars thirty bucks alright sweet so
that was Necropolis guys and thank you
very much for joining right
you